[Musica]
esiste una terra bellissima e colori
straordinari subirà nei profumi di
paesaggi mozzafiato dove si mangiano
cibo nativo primitivo antico dove si
beve di più
meglio una terra abbandonata derisa
snobbata il piena zeppa di seconde case
vuote di ordine state di buio solitudine
d'inverno su una terra di mosè di
silenzi di grano di patate di mele di
noccioli darà piena zeppa di tempo che
va violenta e un volto e che scandito
dalle stagioni
questa terra magica è la chiave è
isolata e al tempo stesso centralisti
una terra in cui non c'è niente ma se
guardi bene può trovare l'infinita
[Musica]
ovviamente dopo il grande illuminare con
esso me un grandissimo fallo beh io non
sono uno specialista di niente nel senso
che non ho studiato qualcosa in
particolare per cui non hanno neanche
tanto le specializzazioni cerco sempre
di mantenermi così un po mezz'aria
anche perché sono tante cose non sono
una cosa sola non saprei minimamente
buttarmi soltanto in una forse per
latitudine o forse perché ho diversi
problemi che non riesco a risolvere per
cui devo necessariamente parlare parlare
di me no perché io sono effettivamente
quello che faccio è per cui non teorizzo
e vi racconto un po quello che combino
in sostanza e parte da genova ovviamente
perché io sono nato a marassi
sono nato a marassi in questo posto dove
ci sono i condomini con nei colori
sbiaditi dove c'è stato di asfalto dove
puzza di piscio i cani dei gatti perché
ovviamente tutti portano loro cane e c'è
questa puzza abbastanza insopportabile e
per cui diciamo che sono cresciuto un po
in quest'ambiente quino dove ci sono
questi cani per strada a fine settembre
con i mali uncini alla dieta berti 9 con
i cani che cazzo se caldo però già di
restano così perché giustamente pensa
sti poveracci animali insomma non se la
sappiano cavare da soli
in questo contesto qui arrivo subito un
punto chiave infatti no perché poi
dicono ma tutta la pellicola città vuoi
mettere
vuoi creare zizzania tra la città
campania non è assolutamente così anzi
sono un grande amante della città tant'è
vero che ci vado spesso vado spesso a
milano vado spesso a genova perché
comunque mia madre olio tile ex otago
che ovviamente mi reclamano bussano e mi
portano giù per cui amo follemente
genova tant'è vero che c'è proprio un
detto che si usa dire proprio nelle
campagne di genova quando apre
un'attività o quando trovi qualcosa in
un paesino che non ti aspetti
dicono bleach toodog mazen ha cioè se
tutto come a genova come se a genova ci
fosse tutto e gli stessi sono gli stessi
che poi dicono che in realtà dove abito
io in appennino
non c'è niente allora io mi domando cioè
quello che stiamo cercando di fare di
domandarsi questa cosa qui cos'è il
tutto è cosa e niente allora io faccio
un po un piccolo elenco e cos'è il tutto
per questa gente qui perché se ne
appennino non c'è niente evidentemente
in città se tutto è tutto è una creperia
un negozio di gucci un ristorante
gourmet in cover story un tribunale uno
stadio un negozio di modellismo una
galleria d'arte di un tuo amico ricco un
ristorante di lusso una tedesca di radar
che fa l'erasmus praticamente stanley
non vanno di certo in appennino
il kebab un'università al carcere il
temporary shop e niente invece cosa
vediamo un po cos'è questo niente un
abete un negozio di alimentari
avete presente quello in cui sotto c'è
il prezzo di plastica che si può poi
togliere modificare nell'eventualità
necessari prassi cioè sempre
poi c'è un cane da pastore il monte
giarolo la polenta e rifugio agli orsi
dicendo cose proprio specifiche no una
poiana una vecchia porta in castagna di
una cascina ma ancora
come un lago l'altopiano il lupo il
ponte di legno da stufa in ghisa larice
una pecora un becco per ed ecco è il
maschio della capra le fagiolane in
umido cioè queste vecchie varietà di
fagioli che a genova si usa proprio
coltivare il genoa cucinare così cioè se
si fanno bollire poi si lasciano la loro
nella loro acqua così la pelle rimane
attaccata legume si condisce banalmente
con un po di olio e sale tanto così per
contestualizzare quello che dico
alcuni ai saperi elementari utile ho
scritto così poi magari mi sbaglio
alcuni saperi elementari utili alla
sopravvivenza e all'evoluzione della
specie ovvero cose stupide ovvero
coltivare il cibo fa report e fare case
con materiali locali farsi la linea per
scaldarsi tutte cose che sono proprio
elementari che non c'è niente e non
valgono forse nulla ma che si fanno
soprattutto lì e cui per cui io mi sono
fatto
tra le mille e mille domande sono
arrivato un po a questo punto cioè penso
che il problema della città sia proprio
il fatto che ci sono tanti sormani anche
solo gli esseri umani
cioè io non voglio credere che gli store
ma li spostano bastare a se stessi no
e siamo così ottusi che crediamo che noi
facciamo tutto ci facciamo alla città
con noi con tutto
no c'è tutto c'è il temporary shop e
tutto e siamo felici ecco io non credo
almeno a me non capita così perché poi
mi annoio gli esseri umani dalla gente
brava gente però poi sono anche a volte
noiosi no c'è anche voglia di fare altro
di incontrare una lepre che ne so di
andati a fare un giro in mente a due
abeti e cose che in città
ahimè ahimé non ci sono insomma comunque
io nasco a marassi per cui facevo le
impennate con motorino rubato le scocche
rubavo specchietti se quelli pieghevoli
non andavano di brutto cioè in rubavo
però nel rubavano anche a me che non ero
solo io
e poi cosa facevo poi alla fine del
passato alla macchina invece alla
macchina non è cambiato nulla perché poi
ho staccato la mia prima macchina
indimenticabile questa for fiesta mi
pare proprio anni ottanta azzurrino che
non ti dico della linea nonna insomma
che c'è lavoro da 6 mesi già avevo
quattro gomme diverse perché non sapevo
che bisogna cambiare la coppia
addirittura per cui bucava la gomma ne
mette con una diversa e andava bene così
fino a quando un giorno e ora in
campagna tanto per cambiare è una sera
matta da un po bevuto e in un passo che
si chiama il passo del bracco molto
molte curve faccio una chicane mi
sembrava di essere in qualche così
competizione non regolamentate
evidentemente il che mi ha portato
contro un muro ecco però non mi sono
fatto niente non so proprio niente
i ragazzi delle prime poco o niente la
musica stecca continuava era una
bellissima scena apocalittica questa
macchina bruttissima contro un muro e la
musica uomo un blu blu e noi diciamo che
è successo perché cosa abbiamo fatto di
male noi effettivamente non c'era
neanche accorte era malato non hai
finito per quella mattina io dormivo sai
che poi quando la mattina dormi non ti
rendi me ne contano e mia nonna che una
santa donna viene da me il tè dormivo e
mi accarezza e mi dice mauri mauri
penisola macchina che cazzo combinato
insomma la macchina ma la macchina è sul
passo del bracco
bisognerà pure andarla a riprendere in
qualche modo va beh va beh insomma
diciamo cambia non avevo un sacco di
cose perché mia nonna e mio nonno mi
hanno dato la possibilità di andare in
montagna ai primi anni indimenticabile
questa ford taunus arancione
metallizzata miano andare uno che andava
sempre con l'acceleratore a bomba che ne
ha 85 anni che mi son perso una volta
che ero andato per funghi bellissima
cosa
sono nato per fondi con mio nonno ma
veramente ormai dodici tredici anni fa
ci siamo persi perché lui fa io e te
sono nato qui figurati se ci guardiamo
io e belen sarà passato di montagna 8
gps ci siamo persi lo stesso poverino
mio nonno era sola in carne per cui mi
ricordo guadare un fiume con le scarpe
stremati dopo 29 ore di cammino vedevamo
di funghi così mani lasciamoli perché
pensavamo a sopravvivere
capisci a dei funghi fino a quando di
verso la statale e sono riusciti a siamo
riusciti a contattare mia nonna con il
telefonino che era già un ottimo segno
non era scontato per niente e vediamo
una un'altra fiesta perché erano super
abitudinari però un po più moderna
passare tipa i 90 all'ora festa statale
la mia nonna che cazzo combina viene la
mia nonna ma no sai come anteo nonna a
favore la morale che poi dopo
mezz'oretta circa a riprendere la capito
dove eravamo
abbiamo a parte queste divagazioni ho
avuto la grande fortuna di andare a
robilante questo paesino di lepri alpi
marittime che appunto all'età di due
anni sono mi ami ami ami ha fatto
conoscere la montagna perché mia nonna
aveva comprato quei soldi del ristorante
un appartamentino anni 80 in questo
condominio veramente dubbio gusto che
però che però mi ha dato veramente la
possibilità di di capire cosa fosse la
montagna e sentirne gli odori e le
vibrazioni eccetera eccetera
metteteci mio no non era tra possibilità
anche lui di andare di conoscere la
montagna ma più che montane a campagna
perché diciamo a carro in provincia di
la spezia sopra sestri levante un
paesino proprio molto caldo molto bello
insomma che mi ha regalato un sacco di
cadute in motorino cicatrici di ogni
genere mio nonno attilio effettivamente
devo dire che è stata una figura molto
importante perché proprio lui che mi ha
un po fatto capire la bellezza proprio
della sobrietà perché lui era uno che
mangiava e non lasciava niente sul
piatto cioè pure le mele bacate ok se li
mangiava lo stesso e con grande orgoglio
se non voleva far vedere che non c'era
niente sul piatto che non voleva
lasciare neanche una briciola erano roba
che mi affascinava figo che attilio
attila si chiamava ma pensate una
sobrietà nave gioia di vivere che mangia
anche le mele bacate e lui mi disse la
quale si sono beccati miliardi di volte
meglio che quello che va a comprare
sicuramente qualche vermetto mi farà
meno male di tutti i pesticidi che
troviamo in quella che compriamo sul
mercato
voi mi direte ma che cazzo ci sta
raccontando che ci frega a noi è vero e
giusto
potete dirmelo io lo accetto io sono
venuto qua proprio perché mi hanno
chiamato e per me il ted una sorta di
brno cioè io sto facendo quello che fa
cenno al bar
solo che al bar di solito non ai folli
però è proprio il bello del tennis
secondo me che è proprio in qualche modo
non cerca di imitare limitare in maniera
non troppo naturale il bar che
l'appennino è un luogo sacro nel bar la
accadono cose che una casa da parte
incontri persone che li vendi soltanto
al bar che ti domandi se vivono al bar
ma probabilmente no di chi soltanto di
sempre sempre ovunque vai qualsiasi
alimentari notevoli
va beh insomma anche qui avrò vi ho
fatto la romanzina sono già dieci minuti
abbastanza cose da dire ma vado subito
vado subito anche se da otto minuti nei
sette minuti domani sfrutto già che ci
sono
no perché sempre rispetto a questo
niente questo tutto no cioè che il kala
gente dice ma cazzo ma sono andato lì ma
non c'era niente in val borbera la valle
dove sono io
appennino ligure piemontese una valle
incredibile
dove ci sono la risi betulle abeti rossi
poi incontri in lupo e poi incontri
cinghiali e poi contro i cervi e poi i
conti caprioli che li maledice perché
entrano dentro la tua vigna nonostante
le mie i miei recinto altri così ma fa
parte del gioco e del resto era il
medico come cannes se possibile che non
c'è niente c'è un sacco di robben
allora mi domando anche i suoi suoni
cosa cioè come cisco perché me ne sono
andato via da genova forse anche perché
c'era un gran casino
se c'è la puzza oltretutto le città
purtroppo non respirano per questo tu
fai la pipì lì e lì rimane
e rimane chissà per quanto invece su una
fa la pipì in campagna poi assume anche
un ruolo poi è azoto liquido facile da
assimilare anche questo mi ha fatto
questa è scienza ragazze c'erano degli
ok e per cui la morale quale che sono
nate fra il contadina 20 anni
soprattutto tutti e dovrà attivare in
campania tipo renato pozzetto
al contrario però cioè in quel localino
di bellissimo così 7 metri quadrati in
cui c'era tutto invece sono andato in
campania proprio vi racconto mille
peripezie in campania case ho vissuto in
qualche caso con una canonica di una
chiesa anni 70 davanti al cimitero per
nove mesi
riscaldamento va beh cosa del genere
aprile cioè cimitero non vi dico che
allegri ha però anche quello è servito
che quello è servito
e fino a quando a 30 anni dopo aver
fatto un po di manovalanza agricola ho
deciso di fondare cascina barban il
progetto collettivo di cui faccio parte
e con il quale vivo di fatto la gente
quando vado in giro vedo le mie mani e
rotte mi dice cosa è successo e mi
spavento perché dico perché cosa c'è che
non va e perché la gente pensa che io
sia un vip
tu a oggi per esempio oggi farò nomi ma
spero che non cambieranno opinione su di
me ma sono venuti a prendere il
presentatore era presentatore
carinissima tra l'altro marito anche io
sul musicista
io ho girato molto e chi cioè no perché
perché effettivamente non so se non sono
musicisti sono uno che veramente alle
vigne favino naturale e cerca di fare
ovviamente un vino che svolge un posto
ruolo no quello di portarti anche altro
rispetto a dove siamo adesso
ma è una cosa seria è una cosa seria
fatto il problema del tempo e non c'è il
vino perché il bar cioè al vino il tetto
no e questo è un grande limite
chissà che magari ma in america in
america che sono siano già arrivati e
tutti lo canzoni e bo mi capita di avere
un po di fortuna che la musica ma di
fatto io scrivo canzoni per me per altri
faccio vino e mi viene tutto abbastanza
naturalmente mi faccio un culo
così.tutti i giorni dalla mattina alla
sera misero 5 da mangiare legale occhi
alle anatre alle galline prevede
dall'asino poi c'è il mio stallone che
non mi vuol parlare con giorno e miss
calcia però conosciuto un ragazzo che fa
il fotografo che mi ha detto come mi
devo comportare perché lui ha detto
anche che fa addestramento con i cavalli
farò e farò tesoro fondo questo progetto
appunto che si chiama cascina barban che
si occupa di biodiversità
l'obiettivo è quello di fare prodotti di
qualità perché banalmente nel senso che
se si ha un gran bisogno per quest'anno
diventati fanatici della biodiversità
agricola e tutte le vecchie varietà ci
fanno godere e cerchiamo sempre di
coltivarne di trovarne di nuove
addirittura abbiamo scoperto col cnr una
varietà di vite rossa in val borbera che
si chiama moscarino soltanto dirlo non
so ma per me era emozionale moscarino il
moscarino quanti ricordi con moscarino
quanti ricordi che cazzo dimostrino che
faremo grazie a mostrino c'è una varietà
a volte un contenitore di miliardi di
cose di lacrime di gioia di volti di
terra di profumi e per cui l varietà
moderne purtroppo queste cose non ce
l'ha
perché sempre perché gli esseri umani
pensano che così in qualche in qualche
lavoratori ha detto facciamo le varietà
nuove che sono migliori no mentre quelle
vecchie hanno sfamato tutti fino ad oggi
ma in centinaia e centinaia di secoli di
selezione sono sono sono passate io non
penso
non penso che sia così comunque in
sostanza cascina verbund avete capito
cos'è e con cascina barbana alla fine è
successo che avevo incontrato un regista
gli ho parlato di della val borbera
dell'appennino di questa idea di tutte
di niente sto regista sei innamorato e
così abbiamo fatto appennino pop questo
progetto fatto ma vi abbiamo imbastito
questo progetto del progetto che si
chiama appennino pop e che vuole proprio
indagare sull'appennino come l'uomo come
luogo cardine invece per l'italia perché
per me il pennino è un po come fosse
l'ultimo no cioè trattato come come
veramente come come come fosse veramente
uno dei peggiori mascalzoni che uno
possa conosce in realtà l'appennino
secondo me ha tantissimo ad offrire da
un laboratorio enorme di nuovi vite e
penso che se si parla di cibo ad esempio
l'appennino abbia miliardi di cose da
dire di più rispetto alla pianura e la
città senza l'appennino secondo me non
dura tanto e per cui abbiamo cominciato
questo progetto crowd funding eccetera
io dovevo fare soltanto un viaggio a
piedi e racconta l'appennino poi
diventato un'arma gigantesca mila pardal
non faccio più vita non faccio più vita
però è una cosa che comunque mi sta
piacendo e per cui continuo a fare e per
cui vi consiglio veramente perché poi
altri tutto l'appennino pop cos'è perché
pop pop perché banalmente vorremmo che
questi temi non hanno non stessero
sempre dentro le cerchi della passionati
o dei montanari come eccetera ma
arrivato nella tavole della gente comune
perché temi la biodiversità agricola i
vecchi saperi il patrimonio
naturalistico sono tutti i temi che
interessano tutti e allora noi stiamo
cercando attraverso le mie abili musiche
che speriamo siano abili ci proverò con
tutto me stesso e ad arrivare proprio a
tanta gente perché perché secondo me
come si può dire sono temi che appunto
devono devono arrivare a tanta gente
cercheremo di far capire alle persone
che in realtà
appunto l'appennino è una cosa grande
per cui in sostanza di tettuccio se non
andate in appennino perché non avete
voglia perché non c'è wifi
perché avete la che cazzo ne so la
l'artista amica che è proprio di città e
non potete lasciarla ma ci sta però non
dite che non c'è niente ok grazie mille
[Applauso]
[Musica]